l'ancien président de la république
jacques chirac a été entendu ce matin
par les juges sur l' affaire des emplois
fictifs du rpr dans une tribune publiée
dans le monde cet après midi il estime
normal et conforme aux principes
républicains de répondre aux questions
du juge c'est la première fois sous la
vème république qu'un ancien chef de
l'état est entendu dominique verdeilhan
et eric lagneau
jacques chirac tout sourire à son retour
cet après midi dans ses bureaux de la
rue de lille 2 - après son départ de
l'elysée pour l'ex chef de l'état le
rendez vous du jour n'avait rien de
politique un tête à tête avec un juge
déclaration à faire bonjour monsieur
quatre heures d'audition et un retour en
arrière au temps où il était à la fois
maire de paris et président du rpr à une
époque où la ville de paris rémunérer
des permanents du parti gaulliste une
pratique qui aurait perduré 2,88 à 95 4
heures d'audition durant lesquelles il a
dû répondre aux questions du juge alain
philibeaux chargé du dossier des emplois
fictifs du rpr dossier dans lequel a
déjà été condamné alain juppé alors
secrétaire général du parti quatre
heures en qualité de témoins assistés
autrement dit avec l'aide d'un avocat
je crois que les explications de
l'ancien président de la république a
fourni aux juges
ont été tout à fait complète
transparente
explicite son rôle sa connaissance des
faits et devrait par conséquent
satisfaire les juges en charge du
dossier pour wii aura pas d'autre
je n'imagine pas qu'il puisse y en avoir
d'autres mais le juge maîtres sont
d'anciennes pas de système organisé dans
le financement des partis politiques
c'est la défense de jacques chirac
devant le juge et dans une tribune du
monde avant la loi de 95 écrit jacques
chirac les responsables politiques de
l'époque ont agi avec probité et dans le
souci de l'intérêt général sept ans de
tâtonnements se sont avérés nécessaires
pour parvenir au bon régime juridique
dans les semaines qui viennent jacques
chirac pourrait recevoir dans ses
bureaux la visite d'un autre juge
d'instruction xavière simeoni
depuis 98 elle instruit le dossier des
chargés de mission de la ville de paris
dossier dans lequel pas moins de vingt
personnes ont été mises en examen